hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm Lauren Francesca I
don't say her name she can speak for
herself
Thanks we're in a new new movement where
men don't need to introduce women see
I'm I'm progressive great I'm white
what's awake woke oh whoa that's the
word gotcha
I need a look at what it means guys
we're gonna watch this try not to laugh
challenge Lauren don't laugh at it it's
with Jim Carrey Oh amazing I'll
definitely that'll definitely work
amazing I can't wait to watch the Jim
Gary's do the comedies huh okay Jim
Carrey is a legend yes I love him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've seen elsewhere do anything to
embarrass me in front I can't what like
this
[Music]
[Music]
this is the one scene for that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think you might have to turn it up
it's good to see you again
nope Thank You laughs now it's called
sexual assault
[Music]
[Music]
deleted scene he was
[Music]
I guess they're right senior citizens
although slow and dangerous behind the
wheel can still serve a purpose I'll be
right back don't you go dying on so many
questions for you
well for starters
that day huh me too
actually everything's been bad since I
broke up with my boyfriend then you know
what the klutz did and good-looking and
I have a rapist week anyway
yeah about my friend you're doing
tomorrow men take Nick Evans for little
girls
could I have just
[Music]
he's really looking that why do you
think I didn't get the anchor job you
know any problems is it right here do
they did not know about disease until
the white man came
oh no sorry I'm a professional
[Music]
his teeth are really white
Oh Oh
[Music]
the search humor every morning to do a
great number of terrible chores
you know
it's a good cut
would you like an ashtray mm-hmm I don't
smoke it's a you're a very nice guy but
I just don't have any room in my life
okay peanut yes I hear it's bulky but I
consider it carry-on peanut oh I see
there's only the other thing that can
make this movement any better what's
that if you had a nice set of knockers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pleasant isn't it yeah too bad cause I
guess the weather is how he's planning
here the winters are remarkably mild
oh is that it
is that it it's over that was a lot of
Jim Carrey right there I just I need to
turn off my phone
thanks very popular whatever you do
don't bring Lauren someone knows you're
here really oh my goodness
see if they wrote me too but I'm gonna
need you to leave all right
but first let's finish this video since
you're here okay but no one can know you
were here here's what all save how Jim
Carrey noises in a compilation in the
first half I thought we're pretty easy
not to laugh at that first those life
you know out of context and you just
show all the noises it's actually kind
of annoying I love like all those movies
you just take them moment sir is
freaking out all together I'm like it's
just noise at this point but then
there's some moments that still just
really make me laugh I don't know what
it is about that Lemony Snicket's moment
we're just doing the Raptor impression
it always gets to me
do you like Jim Carrey yeah do you think
he's like this in real life
no I rented the movie for $5 off Amazon
called Dumb and Dumber to amazing and
then I stopped watching it about 30
minutes and because I was like this is
just annoying you could tell what Jim
Carrey is I grew up on him and I loved
him he's a legend and then he watch
movies like liar liar they are greatness
directories then they made Dumb and
Dumber one which is one of my favorite
comedies of all time Peter Farrelly just
won an Oscar for a green book and
everyone was happy about that I'm so
happy actually I've met both of them and
they're so nice oh oh you can't like
there you go throwing names around I saw
Peter after he
at one green book he's so humble he's
like talking to everyone that is so good
and I'm not talking about the direction
of dumb and number two Peter Farrelly
and Bobby Farrelly are amazing human
beings
Lauren Francesca approved let me talk
but Jim Carrey for oh that's sick now
when you see many interviews and stuff
he's known to like becomes a very
heavily philosophical guy yeah right
talking about universe's spirituality
incidental meditation yeah I've tried it
cuz of him he has evolved and then it's
like he had this career path where it
seemed like he wanted to do a little bit
more serious work did you watch Mister
Rogers I haven't seen they everything I
heard he's amazing in it it's kind of
depressing
but but he's amazing yeah yeah yeah and
it's a and I was loving the dramatic
work he was doing and then it sort of
seemed like he was getting pushed to go
back into a little bit more of like old
Jim Carey than nineties and and I
thought he might have had like a bit of
a Tom Hanks career where tommix did a
lot of comedies and he evolved this
great dramatic actor and I thought Jim
Carrey was kind of headed for that path
a movie like eternal sunshine Truman
Show right he's incredible my favorites
and Dumb and Dumber to his performance
of that and then a couple of other
movies I felt like he was trying to do
90s Jim Carrey wouldn't seem like he
wasn't that guy anymore him and Jeff
Daniels in that movie just felt like it
was kind of forced I was like yes man as
a movie I loved and I thought that was a
good hybrid of something a little bit
more subtle back with moments where you
do get the really over-the-top Jim
Carrey because at the end of the day no
one could do with Jim Carrey has done or
can do uh-huh like liar liar you watch
that movie you're like who else could
have done this like no one else could
have done it the way he's doing it to be
that over-the-top but still be
believable and this character is
incredible yeah
Ace Ventura another great example I mean
he made talking with your ass a really
popular thing Dumb and Dumber my guy
like who can do these were like only Jim
Carrey could have done those
performances you know thing is with the
noises at a contest it's kind of
frustrating yeah but then there were a
few moments are like I know that was
that was a pretty funny moment still you
know I was watching you because you were
trying not to laugh and I was trying to
figure out how to see
not laugh at some of these moments cuz
like it's just a laugh comes and you
can't even you don't even feel it oh I'm
a professional at non laughing oh yeah
oh yeah you know like my friends are
always making jokes around my girlfriend
and I don't want my girlfriend laughing
anyone elses jokes mine I'm very
conservative now if she ever watches one
of these videos she doesn't watch this
channel would she ever watches any of
the videos so if other guys are making
jokes around her I don't laugh uh-huh
I don't want them to think they're funny
not around my girlfriend I'm very
possessive like that I've been told I'm
controlling uh-huh
but you know I just call it passion
passion there's a difference okay
I don't know why you segue there I I
didn't bring it okay just we're gonna
stay on topic instead of awkwardly
transitioning the topics here he's great
you did it you smoothly brought it back
well most people clicked off right after
the reaction was done anyway so what's
your favorite Jim Carrey movie comment
below check out Lauren on Facebook a
bunch of stuff she's everywhere follow
me her goal is to dominate the Internet
you could subscribe to the real rejects
we have notification bells
I want your pitch and a shout to a man
named Daniel Gallagher Daniel I know
this is a weird video to show you out on
I'm gonna talk a lot about comic book
movies and such all the time cinema in
general Daniel you have been gifted
something very special we are now
officially friends on my private
Facebook page Wow
I don't even think we're friends on your
private face never will be use this
wisely you don't want to DM me too much
on my private Facebook page you will get
blocked really blog people I will block
if you talk to me too much and I will
make very vulgar posts
some call them harassment if you
slightly get on my nerves or if you just
happen to post something I kind of don't
like so use this gift wisely Daniel
Lauren you still got a few years to earn
I just I gotta donate to you on patreon
that's pretty much the only way you
become friends
I don't even log on it would just exists